[Music]
[Applause]
so i am a little confused because
i've never done a magic trick where i
have the deck of cards and i have no
idea how you can possibly trick me here
do you have a deck of cards yeah yeah
and do you are you
are you skilled with cards at all i'm
definitely going to do this to peter
mccann and i'm very curious
how he's going
i'm okay
at identifying what's happening i'm not
like dexterous with my fingers though i
have to have a deck of cards yeah i have
to be prepared for this yeah you know
just one prop one problem uh
i definitely have a deck of cards yeah
that's the only
a deck of pokemon cards does that work
ah
can you give me three minutes to look
for a deck of cards here i'll try i'll
try something else with with this deck
it's fun when you have a deck but
i'm gonna have you pick a card and see
if i can uh
okay something see how this is all a
totally
normal shuffle deck of cards
okay so i'm gonna have you
take a look through these cards i'm
gonna like riffle them to you
and just real fast and see if you can
pick out a card and don't say it out
loud let's see if you can pick one out
right okay all right
to the camera gotta get the frame rate
got it you got it okay so you can pick
we could have picked whatever card but
you got one
so
i'm gonna see you can see this right
yes i'm just going to take the deck like
this and just like totally mix it up
face up
face down
all over the place so it's completely
trash like there's no way you could see
like
your car could be anywhere in here any
one of these cars right it could be face
up it could be face down look some of
them are
back to front
some of them are
front to back oh look some of them are
back to back like it could be anything
but sure i'm going to put them
in this nice little neat pile
[Music]
make sure you can keep seeing them
and
would it impress you
if if i turned all of these cards
to face one direction
yes it would definitely impress me it
would
yes okay cool
they're all facing one direction
okay
that was pretty smooth did you catch
that there's there's one card
there's one card
that's not facing that oh my god that's
my card is it is it really
oh that's not good
that's good
all right that's pretty impressive
that's pretty impressive
thank you thank you
i guess
last time we spoke we were in the middle
of the desert in arizona you had just
come down from this balloon trip
from was it twenty thousand feet how how
did you go
i actually went to 25 000. 25 000 which
was on my watch but he yelled no no
don't pull you after he said go go go
and it was really so registered is 24 9
on there okay but i was at 25 on my
watch i was on the ground i could see
everybody like talking to you in like
the whole broadcast set up and that was
a fun time you know what threw me for a
loop i'm happy it was safe and it was
for my daughter and she was there and i
wanted to keep it happy and fun and all
that stuff
i wanted to go
higher than anything on earth so mount
everest was 29 000 feet a little more
than 29 072 feet or something like that
yeah i guess because the fa and
everybody suddenly
thought that i was going to go hypoxic
because i wasn't doing the proper o2
breathing so suddenly i'm being remote
popped down
and i can't keep i'm like where come on
what's going on i want to keep going so
anyway but but it was a lot of fun when
because they were able to remote pop
everything yeah they did as soon as i
deployed jumped down they recovered the
entire rig
that was a high-tech experiment like i
got to see the like the aftermath of
like so you jump out they've got the
remote control and like tracking of this
huge
rig essentially an aircraft it continues
to fly they lower it to the ground they
recover it like i got to see all that
happen yeah i was very impressed with
the amount of tech happening even though
at its core it's you with some balloons
which was amazing but if it was just me
and the balloons then it would have
actually been something that i wasn't
into because i didn't want to just leave
balloons to go float away and like
destroy the invite you know whatever
don't pop in the desert yeah so that's
that so the big
big team and all the work really was on
how do we recover the rig how do we
bring everything back down which is they
remote pop every single balloon and then
lower it yeah so so you put that on
youtube yeah and one of my favorite
things about like i'm pretty sure i
found and i'm sure a lot of people
watching this have found your magic on
youtube somewhere
and if i look back far enough you're
easily one of i don't speak to a lot of
people who have been uploading to
youtube longer than me but you're one of
the first people to like blow up on
youtube people know david blaine magic
from yeah it came yeah it started with
youtube so how did you why did you
decide to put stuff on youtube because i
know my answer but like sharing magic
i felt like the medium was was changing
so i felt like the natural progression
and and now it really is now the only
way people look at things is on their
phones which is unfortunate but
therefore there's also the fortunate
part which is they have lots of access
to anything that they can think of so
you can learn anything from anyone
anyone anywhere in the world anytime
which is really speeding up the process
of the learning curve which is amazing
but
now
there's youtube
instagram
uh tick tock which i haven't figured out
yet i'm so it's so
it's so cool on the same page with the
exact i think yeah yeah but no no but
i'm not against any of it because i i
actually like all of it but it's just i
have my brain hasn't understood how to
do that yet because it's like
with
youtube it was kind of like magic was
perfect because it was like here's a
trick here's a reaction boom that's
really that that's and that content is
quick and it's gratifying but then you
know it it started to move too like
there's no time for anything it has to
be like the fastest trick and the
fastest reaction couple seconds yeah
yeah yeah quick hits yep i mean i i
remember i've seen a lot of your videos
and magic and that was that was actually
part of the entertaining part was
that takes you into a sort of a rabbit
hole and you just watch as many as you
can you can't get enough and the
reactions from people when you do a
trick to them and blow their mind
is i think you described it this way
it's like this universal language like
everyone has the same
like primal mind-blown reaction to a
good trick
yeah
youtube lets you share that with way
more people than if it was just one at a
time yeah yeah that's right it allows
you to to reach anybody anywhere in the
world
which is incredible
no idea how you can possibly trick me
here yeah that's this is what makes it
good so you've got the whole deck with
you
no way i could
manipulate it or anything so i'm gonna
have you do some stuff and i'm gonna
find your card right
it's a new it's a new camera thing
going
okay so you've got your deck right here
so
don't let me see
but from the top of the deck just start
dealing cards down onto the table in
front of you however many you want and
somewhere before halfway you can stop so
you can keep it below the camera make
sure i can't see it so whenever you want
to stop i'll keep talking so i can't
hear i can't count but as whenever you
want to stop you can stop dealing cards
at a time you can do three at a time
whatever you want to do a random number
before halfway and just stop just let me
know when you're good good we're good
okay so don't show me your don't show me
your hand okay don't show me how many
but what you're gonna do is
take the top card
and flip it over and check and see what
it is
okay and then flip it back over so
that's your card don't let me see it
but just remember what that card is okay
there's no way i can know what this card
is at this point but what we're gonna do
is like if for example it was a three
you'll take three cards from the big
pile and put them face down on top of
your card so if it was a five
you put five on top if it was
a jack it's eleven
i quite like it if you turn around oh my
god yeah
he's turning around i can't possibly see
how many you're dealing you're putting
them on top
right so this is just so you you
definitely remember your card you know
the number and everything
then take that small pile pick it up put
it on top of the big pile
it goes back into one deck got it
amazing below the camera that was
perfect so you agree there's no way i
could know
what card you've got where it is in the
deck
it could be anywhere right you could
have picked whatever you wanted i'm
gonna have you
start dealing from the top
one card at a time
and you're going to read the cards to me
one at a time so i'm going to turn them
over and tell you what they are you're
going to turn them over and tell me what
they are one at a time right
four although wait sorry pause one
i want to have you
cut the deck
from the middle okay okay put that you
put that back on top right so take that
from the middle
cut the entire deck in half so you've
completed the cut yep
there you go yes and then cut it and put
it back on top so now you've swapped the
top and the bottom
perfect okay so now we're gonna deal
from the top one at a time
face down
until we've got
your card we'll go all the way through
two of hearts
three of hearts
ace of clubs
six of hearts
seven of hearts
eight of hearts this was a fresh pack
nine hearts
queen of clubs king of clubs
king of diamonds
you're holding a card in your hand
queen of diamonds oh yeah
keep going keep going jack of diamonds
and then we've just got
ace of
hearts
wow
that you did not shuffle that very much
i did not shuffle that very much you saw
me unbox the pack do you agree that
there is no chance i could there's no
technology i could possibly use to like
you know turn off center stage and like
check your hand or like see anything
there's no like incredible audio feature
that could let me hear how many you
counted or anything like that there's
just
there's no way you don't know where i
cut the deck and i put the bottom half
on top
so no
i don't think you have any idea yeah
okay okay um
well you're right i do i do have a card
here um i'm curious if
your card
is also this card
how did you do that
ah did i
did i get it
i got it right two of clubs
okay that's a pretty good start
it's like you reached through the phone
and like messed up my deck for me what
so
now there's a sort of a new chapter
because i've seen all these i've seen
all these tricks and all these
incredible things you've done
but
you've now decided to make a class and
actually teach magic so i've been
reluctant forever to do magic kits or do
any of those types of things which is
ironic because my mother's a teacher and
my brother's a teacher so they're both
teachers so i always do
understand the amazing and important
effect that you have by teaching people
stuff that you're that you worked really
hard on but i was still reluctant
because magic is such a a confusing area
because these secrets are so powerful
but you don't want to just give them
away because that's part of the art
itself
so every time somebody said to me though
could you teach me a trick i always feel
bad that i can't you know it's like i
want to of course i want to and often i
do teach them something quickly like
i'll be like here i could teach you
something but that's not really
good enough so the idea of being able to
create
any kind of class that i wanted
with studio which is max called me up
and he was he understood all about magic
he did all of his research he could
perform magic he also learned how to
play chess so he could play magnus and
he lasted quite a few moves against him
and he learned how to memorize a deck so
when he showed me all these things he
said i'll do whatever you want to make
this class something that's incredible
and amazing yeah
it was it was it was very difficult to
say no to that because
and i know if anybody wants to take the
class they're not just going to get the
secrets they're going to be they have to
actually enroll they have to like commit
to it it's a month-long class
so
the idea of a student trying to learn
some of the things that were what got me
started some of the basic things in
magic that i love i think that was kind
of the inspiration and that's what led
me to agree to do this yeah so being
able to put out something actually good
and like that you have control over and
that you can really make amazing and
share this with as many people as
possible is
that's like 2022 david blaine that's
pretty sick it's dope
i i also want to ask you like how do you
decide
what stuff
to to share in the class versus what
stuff you continue to work on and evolve
so most of the stuff that i share is
actually for
beginners for people that are you know
beginner intermediate people that want
to be able to like walk into a situation
and do some magic and not you know it's
i think it's such an amazing art form
and it's so
it's so such a deep dive into
psychology it's
technical it's math it's science it's
logic it's all these things combined
and there's a philosophy behind it so i
feel like the people that you know come
come into it
i feel like they'll have a a a new
appreciation for the actual art of magic
itself actually i think like you're
gonna suddenly realize oh wow when this
magician's doing a trick he does it's a
lot of work it's not just like he's
doing this quick trick that has no
meaning and it's like oh he learned it
for
three seconds and now he can do it's
like oh wow
these guys all these magicians out there
work really hard at their craft and it's
special can confirm i mean you're seeing
it now but you've taught me a little bit
i've been working on the tricks i can't
even do this
yeah but you learned it fast wait let me
see if i can do one right now what is it
called again charlie cut yeah you
learned it fast is there a person yeah
there you go
yep perfect it's not yeah it's deep no
you just did it but you learned it fast
but that's the that's the type of the
next phase would be like this oh see
that's just the next would be like this
these are the ones that but these are
the ones that i don't go into teaching
because these are you know this is
this is different i do like the
those things the evolution of a trick
like here's level one here's level two
here's level three that's that's sick
take this whole deck and and divide it
into three like roughly equal sized
piles in front of you and don't shuffle
before
uh you it's shuffled already i think
right you got a couple shuffles in so
give me three equal sized piles in front
of you don't let me see them
and you can
you know adjust it make sure they're
about three equal sized piles
okay they're pretty good you want to see
them no you're good just leave him i
don't want to see i don't i don't want
to cheat and like see the
see the the cards
oh yeah you know this
technology is crazy i might be able to
see through the cars so
take any one of those piles
and flip it face up whichever one you
want
okay the whole thing's face up
yep and you've got a card now on the top
of that pile
yeah that's your card so remember that
card commit that to memory
there's no way i could know it that's
your selection
yeah and then what i want you to do is
take that face up pile the whole thing
and put it on top of one of the face
down piles
okay
right uh
uh still up though still face up yep
and then take
the other face down pile
and put it on top of the face up pile so
you just made a sandwich
yep
so you got all your cards in here now
some of them are face up some are face
down
and uh do your best to like roughly in
the middle
cut the deck and don't complete the cut
so you just have two piles now am i
showing this to you nope nope don't let
me see it okay cut it in half
you've got a face up half and a face
down half and just put them into each
other this is the part where you give me
uh your uh little riffle shuffle one of
these
so we're really mixing up
nah nah off camera the whole thing just
mixing the crap out of this deck right
now you are making me ruin these cards
you still remember your card right you
still got it on my card okay perfect
well like there are like half of them
are up and half of them are down yeah
it's it's crazy it's pretty messed up
right now just for fun just give me a
give me another cut just just cut it in
half and complete the cut like that
so like there's really truly no way you
can cut it again if you want like just
making sure there's
absolutely no chance in these 52 cards
that i could know what it is where it is
it's face up face time whatever right
yeah
so i want you to take this deck you've
you've shuffled
and one at a time from the top
deal the cards into a pile
and
each one that is face up
read the card out loud but don't like
let me see it don't change your voice if
you hit if you hit your card or not just
say all them the exact same so i could
never know just read through the deck
one at a time deal them face up
let me know which ones are face up deal
them all one on top of another all right
king of spades
ace of diamonds
queen of spades
three of clubs
that's it
that's it okay
you know the crazy stat about like
like a card deck can be in any order
like there's like some crazy number of
like orders it can be in like 52
factorial it's like more more stars in
the universe or something like that yeah
um it would be pretty miraculous if from
that shuffle from all that we just did i
could find
your card i might be shocked i'd be
pretty shocked there's no text i would
be shocked
i would be shocked i would be shocked
actually
you know what's funny actually i
uh i have another i have a pocket on the
other side
you remember no way dude okay
you've seen these
okay
and uh
so again i'd be shocked if this worked
but
let me know uh if this is also your card
holy [ __ ]
no
way
no way
did i
i got it
sounds like i got it
you've done
like these tricks to almost any person i
can name has experienced some sort of
incredible magic who's your uh
who's your favorite reaction you've
gotten
i mean you know there's so many amazing
reactions but you mean on somebody like
well known or whatever maybe you did a
trick and you just were like i can't
believe this person loved the trick so
much i mean i i was once at a dinner
with uh a dear friend of mine
and
mickey rourke and tupac
and you know tupac we were at cafe to
back and he was smoking at the table so
he's a little buzzed and i start doing
magic to him and the next thing i know i
look over and he's like on the floor
laughing like kicking his legs like a
little kid and that was yeah that was a
pretty and he's also tupac you know so
that was a pretty exciting
reaction but there's all kinds of
reactions that i get that are amazing
and sometimes it's the opposite it might
just be somebody's completely still like
a kid that i did magic to in a barstow
and i made a coin disappear over saying
it was in my first show i've seen that
yeah yeah and he just stood there
and he's like cool and that was all and
i obsessed over him but you know and
then i wanted to put that trick on abc
and they were like no it's not his
reaction i was like this is the best
thing and then after that i think he got
a taco bell commercial or something
that's an iconic and that's all over
youtube that's exactly that's what i'm
talking about see and then what was
funny was those spoof videos that came
like not that long ago like 10 years ago
or something had those like david blaine
street magic videos
did you enjoy those yeah
that was some of my favorite videos
now that guy mikey day has uh he got a
uh a lead in snl after that that's
incredible
that's incredible you know magic these
types of things they're all creative i
view you as a creator basically this is
what i'm saying like you you put stuff
online you adjust the way you present
you you're creative in the way you
combine things
and you're able to to make something new
and that it's like amazing and you get
to share with people and that's like
inspiring for me so i appreciate that
thank you but hold on i want to say one
other thing marquez so so like i said i
always try to teach people magic yeah
right like i'm always like
the way you are with your hands and your
ability to learn it's it's it's
mind-blowing it was a very fast learning
curve as you know it just that was i was
very impressed you know and and once
again
that was part of my excitement in the
beginning was just i know you're so
athletic you're so smart you're so
telling so
seeing the immediate
learning curve was inspiring and then
you pulled the stuff off quickly yeah
yeah no i i had the best teachers so i
definitely had a pretty pretty good head
start there yeah but you you you the way
you learned it and the way you pulled it
off right away we did it to your crew
did it over zoom yeah and you improvised
you came up with stuff so that you know
that that was for me
that wasn't that's worth the whole thing
right there like watching you learn and
adjust and and come up with things and
it was fun
if your card
is the eight
of clubs
it isn't
it's fine i was just kidding is it this
one
[Laughter]
[Music]
did i get it
i think i got it what the hell that
looks like i got it
you're reaching through my screen it's
not even fair
he learned he learned he learned very
fast what
it took a second it took a second
i was by the way i didn't help him
i mean i taught him but i didn't help
him there's a difference
i don't have like someone who works at
crete airport all right all right i
guess you learned from the master but
that's legitimately really impossible
appreciate it thank you but how could he
have known what you were thinking
regardless oh [ __ ]
what's up man how you doing
by the way just so you know
just you know i was watching so even
though he put the cards at a frame
nothing funny was done he did all of
what you saw exactly
wow yeah i didn't help at all he did it
all himself that whole thing
that is super impressive well call us
back one day when you have your own deck
of non
non-pokemon
he pulled off the impossible
wow david i've watched a lot of your
stuff online over the years you're
you're magnificent i think you just got
a a dose of the the new version of being
able to do this through the screen like
that is unbelievable but there's
something really
eerie about controlling your own deck
and controlling your own cuts and your
own shuffles away from you and just
happening like that is bizarre
face up
oh hold on this is weird hold on tilt
the camera down move the pile in your
hand away move it away move it away you
drop him get rid of him look what he's
been holding since before this began
turn it shown
and by the way you didn't even you
turned them upside down right side up
you did what you wanted
[Music]
i wish i had more time to take this in
this has blown my mind all right shout
out to david blaine himself for teaching
me magic literal dream come true also we
had a full-on longer extended
conversation with some really
interesting questions so i'm gonna put
that entire chat on the next episode of
the waveform podcast you can subscribe
to the waveform channel right here
and uh we also did some magic in the
studio i did some tricks to the people
here but david also taught us how to
hold our breath for like four minutes
straight on the first try it was kind of
amazing so subscribe to the studio
channel here to see when that drops and
then of course uh all the links are
below check out his class if you want to
learn magic from the literal goat
figurative but you know what i mean
okay thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
you